you are so identified with this like the
iconic role of Stifler you must have
people in all these years and the good
news is you take good care of yourself
you look exactly the same you know what
I mean you've always looked 45 but but
do people like think you're Stifler do
you have situations where people like us
identify you so much with that character
that ya know people think that my guy I
think they think that I'm Stifler and
like in the beginning of my career I was
like really that fictional character
yeah and then you could see like certain
guys like kind of frat guys that pretty
much allowed me to have a career or when
they would come up to me like Stifler
and when I said not really it was like
they're you I was breaking their heart
you were telling them you were telling
them there's no Santa Claus exactly
exactly then I realize I'm like watch
yeah yeah and I just I understood then
as like I can't do that to them so now
you just say like yeah I'm Stifler you
know see you've joined in the madness I
have yeah